[Music]
AI is transforming everything.
Healthcare, finance, automation, digital
marketing. But one thing holds it back,
and that's
trust. How do you run models on
sensitive data without handing it over?
How do you deploy proprietary models
without losing control? And how do you
collaborate, especially in
non-deterministic environments, without
relying simply on blind trust? Well,
that's what confidential AI solves. And
that's what Super Protocol makes real.
GPUless, trustless,
limitless. And this session is about
what those words actually mean and how
developers can apply them to run, scale,
and monetize AI workloads securely. So
whether you're building with sensitive
data, proprietary models, or untrusted
partners, you'll see how confidential AI
opens up new possibilities. So we'll
start by breaking down the core
technology behind confidential AI and
then walk through a number of real demos
to see how it works in practice. Let's
start with the foundation, confidential
computing.
This solves one of the most overlooked
problems in AI today, which is that your
data and your model are most vulnerable
not when they're stored or in transit,
but while they're being processed,
whether that's during training,
fine-tuning, or inference. And that's
where trusted execution environments or
TE's come in. At the hardware level, a
TE is it's a secure and isolated part of
the processor like Intel TDX or AMD
SEVSMP or Nvidia GPU TES. It creates
what's called a confidential environment
where code and data are protected even
during
execution. The chip itself provides the
isolation using instructions built into
it during manufacturer.
So once a workload enters this
environment, it's protected in memory
invisible to the host OS hypervisor or
in fact even anyone with system access,
even the owner of the hardware. And it's
not just about
isolation. A TE also generates a
cryptographic at a station. That's
assigned proof that the workload ran
inside verified hardware using
unmodified code. So this is important
for two reasons. Not only do you need
strong assurances that the workload is
truly protected by the hardware, but at
astation also allows us to make
statements about the work what the
workload actually is. So add a
stationation lets you know not only
what's in the TE but also that it's a
real TE in a properly manufactured TE
capable chip because if you can't be
sure of those two facts then you can't
be sure of anything about the workload
or what it's processing. So in short, a
TE lets you run sensitive computations
securely and prove that they ran as
intended. And that changes everything.
It means we can now run AI models even
on sensitive data without exposing them,
the model or the data. That's the
foundation of what we call confidential
AI.
So, let's look at where and why you
might care about this. In particular,
what about some real world problems that
developers face and why is this shift to
confidential AI critical? We'll start
off with
healthcare. If you've ever tried to
build or fine-tune a medical AI model,
you know the hardest part isn't the
model, it's the data and not processing
it, just getting it or permission to use
it in the first place.
Hospitals and labs just don't share raw
data sets, even if your model can
improve patient
outcomes. In research, access to
clinical data is tightly controlled,
expensive to generate, and often siloed.
And you can't just bring your model to
the data, not under current regulations
or security policies. And this all means
that trying to train medical AI models
on real data can take months of
negotiation to get access to even small
data sets. And working across data sets
from multiple providers can be well
nossible. This is what confidential AI
can help
solve. Another topic, personal AI
agents. Those are the ones that manage
your inbox, calendar, or documents. and
they're already being built, but mass
adoption is still out of reach. Why?
Well, one of the main reasons is because
these agents need deep access to
private, sensitive data to be truly
useful, and that triggers concerns
across the board. Users don't want to
expose their personal data. How can I be
sure it's not being shared? Developers
don't want to store it. How can they
protect it from being stolen or misused?
And enterprise and regulators won't
greenlight this use without strong
guarantees. How can we all be sure that
we won't be
sued? So confidentiality isn't a nice to
have. It's a the missing piece that's
actually holding back real world
adoption of these
technologies. Our next example is
digital marketing. In digital marketing
and custom analytics, everyone wants to
fine-tune models on real user behavior,
tracking how users interact with various
websites, content, and online services.
But between privacy laws, internal
security rules, and well, basic basic
ethics, working with that data often
risks upsetting regulators and auditors
or is downright blocked. It's a massive
gap between what's technically possible
and what's actually allowed.
And what about AI model
monetization? Let's say that despite the
various complications and regulations
that need to be navigated, you've built
a domain specific model for legal,
medical, or financial use. Of course,
you want others to use it, and you want
to get paid for it, but you're not
willing to give away your model or its
weights for free, which you risk if you
allow people to run it themselves
without protection.
At the same time, customers aren't
willing to expose their sensitive data,
not for testing, not for production. So,
they won't trust you to run your model
with their data. In other words, both
sides want the benefits without giving
up control. And the good news is with
confidential AI, neither party has to
relinquish that control.
Let's talk about model training and
proof because there's another typically
overlooked problem and that is
provenence. The key question is simple.
Even if you have managed to train or
fine-tune your model on sensitive data,
how do you prove its provenence allowing
users to track back to the initial data
sets?
In other words, how can you guarantee
that a model was really trained where
and how you say it was? With a tested
execution, this becomes possible. The
provalence of the data can be assured
with proof that the answers or outputs
that you get at the inference stage
relate back to the initial data sets and
only the original data sets.
So, in all of the cases we've just
discussed, traditional cloud setups fall
short. They're built on trust and legal
contracts, not on provable guarantees.
And these limitations are exactly why we
built Super Protocol, to make
confidential AI not just possible, but
usable. What we're going to do next is
walk through how it works and what it
unlocks. It's time to talk about Super
Protocol. What is Super Protocol? Well,
Super Protocol is a confidential AI
cloud and marketplace built for secure
collaboration and monetization of AI
models, data, and compute. What are some
of the pieces? Well, we have first of
all, we have a TE agnostic
infrastructure. What does that mean?
Super already runs on Intel, Nvidia, and
AMD TEES. And as major chip makers
continue to include TE's as a core part
of their strategy, we'll support those
platforms
too. It means edge ready architecture.
We've validated ARM confidential
computing via ARM 9 uh emulation
confirming full compatibility with our
architecture. So as ARM 9 based chips
roll out broadly across Android devices
now 70% of the smartphone market we aim
to deliver end toend confidential AI
from personal edge devices straight to
the
cloud and we're built on swarm computing
principles which means that we scale
across distributed GPU nodes with no
single point of failure and automatic
workload redistribution in case of
server downtime.
And we're fully decentralized with no
human intervention, entirely
orchestrated by smart contracts on BNB
chain. And there's no barrier to entry,
zero barrier entry because you don't
need TE expertise to run or a Testa
workloads. And maybe best of all, all
parts of Super Protocol will be open
source because it's a protocol, not a
service. Think about the HTTPS protocol.
It keeps your data safe when you send
that data online. And super protocol
does the same but for AI. It protects
your data while AI is working on it. It
sets a new standard for keeping data
safe during AI
computing. What do we mean by GPUless?
Well, this isn't about removing GPUs.
It's about removing dependency. Because
with super protocol, you can run
accelerated AI workloads across
independent GPU nodes without being
locked into any cloud vendor or
centralized provider. You don't need to
buy GPUs, nor do you need to rent them
for longer than you're using them.
Whether you're training on your own
server or accessing GPUs through the
marketplace, you keep
control. And thanks to the nature of
TEES and super protocols open source
architecture, no unauthorized access is
technically possible. Not by the
hardware provider, not by super
protocol, not by any third party. That's
what makes confidential computing the
foundation of trustless
AI. And then there's limitless.
Limitless is about removing the
blockers, the legal, the technical, and
the organizational barriers. With
confidential AI, you're not limited by
policy, regulation, or infrastructure
constraints. Because traditional cloud
platforms impose limits on data, on
geography, and on control. You can't
access GPU instances without approval.
You can't access sensitive data sets,
collaborate across borders, or monetize
your model your model without handing it
over. And traditional clouds are
especially unfit for agentic
non-deterministic AI where autonomous
agents interact, make decisions, and
evolve in real time. Most cloud
environments just weren't built for that
kind of dynamic multi-party logic.
Super Protocol removes those limits. You
can train, deploy, and monetize AI
across organizations and jurisdictions
with full confidentiality and
ownership. Agents can compute,
communicate, and adapt without
predefined scripts or centralized
control. Confidential,
permissionless, limitless. Now, let's
look at two great end customer case
studies from digital marketing and the
healthcare industry.
Digital marketing first. Imagine Mars,
your favorite confectionary company,
running hundreds of ad companies all
over the world. The digital global ad
market is massive, worth around $600
billion dollars a year, but every week
ad wastes budget.
Realize is a company that uses AI to
measure how people react to ads by
analyzing tiny facial expressions. They
help brands like Coca-Cola and Mars
choose ads that really truly connect
with people. But to make their AI even
more accurate, realize needed much more
biometric video from external partners.
And that's where the problem started.
Privacy laws like GDPR and CCPA along
with concerns about data ownership made
providers reluctant to share sensitive
footage. So for its Mars project realize
used super protocols confidential AI
cloud AI training ran inside secure
environments in other words tees using
powerful chips like Nvidia's H100s and
H200's and Intel Xeons.
Every step was automated by smart
contracts and verified by both the
hardware and super protocols open-source
certification which meant that
throughout the process the data and the
models stayed completely secure proven
to be inaccessible even to the cloud
provider to super protocol or to realize
themselves. Verifiable confidentiality
changed everything because once
providers knew their data was truly
protected, they shared four times more
sensitive footage, growing the training
set by
319%. With that boost, accuracy jumped
to 75% on par with human level
performance. And to Mars, it paid off. a
3 to 5% sales increase across 30 brands
in 19
markets. The takeaway, when data privacy
is provable, lock data gets unlocked,
powering better models, smarter AI, and
real business impact. That's the super
protocol advantage. Transforming privacy
into performance and confidence into
revenue, not just for digital marketing,
but for every datadriven industry.
Now it's time to talk about healthcare.
In fact, let's talk about BEAL, the
Brain Electrphology Laboratory. They
were racing to submit a new epilepsy
diagnostic device to the FDA. BL creates
advanced medical devices and AI tools to
help diagnose epilepsy and sleep
disorders. But to get FDA approval, they
needed to submit perfect documentation.
That usually takes two to four weeks of
manual audits, multiple NDAs, and
carries the risks of exposing trade
secrets. Even one small mistake could
cause a 120day delay in review, slowing
down patient access and return on
investment. They wanted to speed things
up using Titonic's AI powered audit
tool. But they had one concern, one big
concern. How to keep Bell's data and
Titonix model safe from exposure in
traditional cloud
environments? The answer Titonix used
super protocols confidential AI cloud.
The audit ran inside secure hardware
environments in TEES using India H100
and H200 GPUs and Intel TDX CPUs.
Every step was automated, orchestrated
by smart contracts and backed by
cryptographic proof. All files and
models stayed encrypted, only readable
inside the secure environment and
completely hidden from Super Protocol,
BL, Titonix or anyone else. The results
were
huge. Audit time dropped from weeks to
just one to two hours. There was zero
risk of leaks. Both Bells and Titonics
IP stayed fully protected and there were
no re-review delays, cutting out those
120day setbacks. The bottom line, Super
Protocol helped Bell move faster, stay
secure, and deliver life-saving tools to
patients much sooner. It proves that
when confidentiality is guaranteed, even
the most sensitive and high-stage
processes like FDA clearance audits can
be transformed. That's the super
protocol
advantage. You want to see a demo, don't
you? Let's focus on the practical part
of today's session so that you can see
and feel how this works in action.
Remember, Super is a confidential AI
cloud and marketplace built for secure
collaboration and monetization of AI
models, data, and
compute. Our first demo is of the Super
AI marketplace. We'll start with an
overview of its interface and core value
prop and then walk through a
step-by-step demo of deploying an AI
model in just a few clicks entirely with
a fully confidential
environment. Let's begin the marketplace
demo with a short overview of the
highlights. The SuperAI marketplace is
built on a confidential and
decentralized architecture. There are no
centralized components or data centers.
A blockchain based ecosystem is used to
manage the relationships and financial
settlements between the
participants. Providers of AI models and
data sets providers of confidential
computing hardware and the clients.
Confidential computing ensures that the
models remain private and authors retain
full control and ownership. Models may
be leased but not downloaded. Nobody has
access to the trusted execution
environment TE during processing which
means that the models and the user data
are off limits even to the clients. The
models are deployed in the TEE and are
accessible via a link or API. One of the
goals of marketplace is to enable
monetization for authors of closed
source models. A variety of scenarios
are offered per hour fixed and revenue
sharing.
Now let's do a speed run through the
marketplace UI and deploy one of the
models. The marketplace supports two
login methods, web 3 and web 2. Let's
log in through
Google. This is the main marketplace of
the models available for deployment in a
variety of categories or
tasks. You can also deploy or publish
your own model. The published models
will remain confidential and not be
available for
download. In this demo, we will deploy
one of the published DeepSseek
models. As you can see, there are many
variants. Let's take this
one. You can see the description
here and also a variety of
quantizations, requirements, and pricing
scenarios.
Let's deploy on the H100
GPU. The order is assembled
automatically, but you can also modify
it manually to adjust the compute
configuration. Let's deploy
now. The order is now being created on
blockchain. The order is now being
prepared for deployment. The engine and
the model will be downloaded into the
confidential computing environment and
get ready for
execution. About 20 minutes have
passed. The order is now deployed at
this link. You can also deploy as an API
and integrate into your own app. And you
can also set up your own
domain. This is the text generation web
UI interface. Here you can interact with
the DeepSeek model.
All right. And now one final step,
verification. Let's copy this
link. Now we input the link into this
tool. It verifies that this model is
deployed in a confidential environment,
that the connection is encrypted, and
that the AI engine has not been tampered
with.
In the next demos, we will show the many
more features and capabilities of super
protocol. Thank
you. Now, let's move to something more
dynamic. Aentic AI is gaining traction
across industries. Let's see how
automation can be built and run inside
super protocol.
Let's explore how to build secure
automated AI workflows for processing
sensitive medical data using N8N
deployed on super
protocol. By running everything inside
TEES inaccessible even to server admins
or super protocol and combining low code
automation with a decentralized
infrastructure, we deliver fully
confidential, compliant and verifiable
medical
AI. In this demo, we will review a
simple use case. A doctor uploads an
X-ray image and the patient's personal
data using a protected web form. That
image along with metadata is passed into
an automated workflow built with N8N
which runs inside a TE on super
protocol. The workflow cleans the input
data, invokes an AI model to analyze the
X-ray and generates a structured medical
report. That report is then emailed
securely to the doctor.
Let's take a look at the system in
action. We've already deployed N8N on
super protocol. Once deployed, the
platform gives us a secure access link.
Opening this URL brings up the N8N user
interface. In production, this direct UI
access is disabled. Every interaction
goes through secure APIs, web forms,
etc. We register or log in and enter the
NN dashboard.
Instead of building a workflow from
scratch, that will take some time. We'll
import one that's already been
prepared. For the workflow to run, we
need to add some credentials in the
credentials tab. API keys to access the
AI model deployed on super protocol or
elsewhere. Gmail credentials for sending
email reports. These are securely stored
and isolated inside the TE. We will add
those behind the scenes.
This example workflow is simple but
demonstrates all the core ideas. Image
processing, data sanitization, AI
analysis, and automated
reporting. Here's how the workflow runs.
The web hook trigger starts the workflow
automatically when data is submitted via
the web form. Data extraction pulls out
the uploaded X-ray and metadata, the
patients ID, name, age, and clinical
information, as well as the doctor's
name and email address.
Then personal data is separated from
diagnostic input. The AI model receives
only the X-ray and symptom description
necessary to generate a diagnostic
result. This result is combined with the
patients personal data to form a medical
report in text, HTML, or JSON. The
latter may be needed to easily integrate
the workflow with hospital systems or
ERPs.
The report is sent to the doctor's
Gmail and also posted back to the web
form
endpoint. Let's quickly walk through the
N8N's user interface. We've already seen
the workflows tab. It's where you build
or import automation flows. Nodes in N8N
are highly customizable and allow you to
make API calls, respond to web hooks,
and write any JavaScript in your
workflow. In the credentials tab, you
can securely manage API keys and login
details. In the executions tab, you can
view current and past runs, successes,
errors, and debugging
data. To debug, switch the workflow to
inactive. Let's submit a sample form
with a test
X-ray. Watch each node execute step by
step.
We can inspect the inputs and outputs of
each node, image, metadata, AI result,
etc. Confirm that the form receives the
response and the email arrives in the
inbox. Everything works within a secure
confidential
environment. To conclude, this solution
easily adapts to other use cases. CT
scans, MRIs, ECGs, and even lab tests in
minutes with N8N's visual builder
secured by super protocols
TEES. No more choosing between
functionality and privacy. Confidential
AI made
simple. Let's look at scaling. You'll
see how Super Protocol enables
distributed inference using VLM across
multiple GPU servers without relying on
any single provider. This is where
GPUless becomes
real. For this demo, we're distributing
inference of a large language model
across multiple GPU servers using
VLM. Under the hood, VLLM partitions the
model by layers and assigns each layer's
computation to a different node in an
overlay network. Great for memory
efficiency and throughput, but by
default, those machines run in
unprotected environments, exposing your
data, model code, and intermediate state
to host
operators. Here's how super protocol
secures it. Every VLM node runs inside a
confidential VM powered by TE hardware,
all tied together over a private overlay
network. data model weights and
intermediate activations are decrypted
and processed only inside each
confidential environment with all inter
node communication encrypted so no
sensitive material ever leaves the
secure boundary or is exposed to any
host. Now let's see this in action.
Launch distributed VLLM inference in
confidential mode and retrieve the
execution report. In our demo we have
four host owners, Alice, Bob, Carol, and
David. They provide TE hardware with GPU
H100200s to super protocol that allows
running a single large LLM across four
GPU nodes in fully confidential mode on
super
protocol. Our custom Docker file is
based on the official VLM repository. We
added a short helper script that can
launch VLM in different modes head and
workers. We also prepared configuration
files for each mode since we need to run
all four participants in different
roles. First, let's build the Docker
image using the build
command. Next, let's export the built
image to a Tarbal archive, which we'll
need for the next step.
Then let's upload the archive into
decentralized storage using a super
protocol CLI tool called
SPCTL. Now it's ready to run on super
protocol. We've prepared four SPCTL
configuration files, one per
participant. First, we launch the master
node head, which accepts all incoming
connections. Since all orders are in the
same overlay network and we know the
internal IP addresses, this is easy to
do. Alice runs her VLM to start the head
node. Super Protocol launches her
confidential
environment and returns an order
ID. Next, let's launch Bob and Carol in
regular worker mode, and they
automatically connect to Alice's head
node and share GPU cycles.
David's node is special. His node
configuration file not only sets the
mode worker, but also specifies which
model to run. In this case, it's Mistral
with 22 billion parameters. Points to
the domain with an SSL certificate and
private key for secure connections.
Includes the headnodes address so it can
join the overlay. launches the model
inference in addition to being a worker.
This parameter shows that the setup uses
four GPUs connected together. We
preloaded the mistraw model so that the
hybrid node can immediately launch
inference across all four GPU hosts in
one confidential workflow. Here Alice,
Bob, Carol, and David are simply the
owners of those hosts. The job itself
runs across their combined
resources. All four orders have deployed
successfully.
We can download the onchain reports and
verify that the image and model hashes
match what we expect. We can do this
verification for each of the four
participants. Each report passes
integrity checks confirming that the
orders contain the correct model and
application.
Finally, let's test the public endpoint.
Anyone can access the provided domain,
verify that everything works, and make
requests. Since processing is
parallelized across four machines,
responses return much faster than
usual. That's it. You've seen how super
protocol enables GPUless distributed
inference fully confidential,
decentralized, and verifiable onchain.
The distributed setup provides both
security through TE hardware and
improved performance through parallel
processing. So, finally, let's talk
about trust, one of my favorite topics,
or rather how you can move beyond it. In
this demo, we'll show how Super Protocol
replaces blind trust with builtin
cryptographic proofs. Every run is
verifiable independently and
transparently down all the way to the
hardware level. So trustless doesn't
mean insecure. It means verifiable by
design. Because every workload produces
a cryptographic proof showing what ran,
where, and how without exposing the
actual workload
data. Now, let's see what makes this
truly trustless. Full verifiability and
trust aren't required anymore. When a
workload runs on super protocol, it
generates a cryptographic attistation, a
signed proof from the hardware itself,
building on the atistation capabilities
inherent in confidential computing.
This attestation verifies that your
model executed in a real trusted
execution environment, a TE using
unmodified code on verified hardware
inside a secure opensource runtime. You
don't have to trust the provider. You
don't have to trust the platform because
you can verify. And even if you don't,
the system won't expose your sensitive
data if there attempts to bypass it.
Simply because the protocol won't allow
your application and data to load and
run if this happens. Here's what that
looks like in
practice. Hi, today we'll demo how Super
Protocol helps data owners and AI model
developers collaborate securely. One of
the toughest business and technical
challenges is training models on medical
data where privacy is crucial. We'll
show how super protocol solves this. We
have three participants. Alice's lab,
Bob's clinic, and Carol's research
center. Alice and Bob each hold
sensitive data sets. Carol brings a
training engine. There's no model yet.
The goal is to train a brand new model
for early cancer detection on Alice's
and Bob's data without exposing either
the data or Carol's intellectual
property. All three inputs, Alice's
data, Bob's data, Carol's training
engine, run inside a trusted execution
environment or TE. No one, not the cloud
host, not super protocol, not even the
participants can access what's inside.
And outside the TE, each party keeps
full custody of its assets. Inside, no
one can see raw data, source code, or
weights. Training is fully automated by
the verified engine, the super protocol
certification center, and smart
contracts on OBNB, BNB chains. Layer
2. In the past, multi-party training
meant legal paperwork, manual setup, and
blind trust. So many projects stalled or
took months or years to get underway.
Super Protocol removes those trust
barriers. It hides the complexity and
automates the entire process behind the
scenes. And you don't need to be an
expert in confidential
computing. At Super Protocol, a
confidential virtual machine or CVM is
launched once and then handles multiple
jobs. No need to spin up a new VM for
every task. On boot, the CVM contacts
the open source certification authority,
also running in confidential mode for a
remote attestation. If the check passes,
the center issues a certificate proving
the CVM is genuine and running inside an
attested trusted execution environment.
But attesting the CVM isn't enough.
Before any data enters, an open-source
security mechanism inside CVM, the
trusted loader comes in. First, it's
attested and gets its own certificate.
Then, it creates a signed key pair and
checks every component. If any of these
checks fails, the process automatically
stops to safeguard all parties and
ensure nobody's data or models are
compromised. Now, let's walk through
that
flow. Carol builds a containerbased
training
engine. Here is its hash.
She uploads her engine image to her own
encrypted storage, provides its hash and
the source code so that the data owners
can verify them. Alice and Bob check
them. To be clear, Carol's engine is
proprietary, but she privately shares
its source code with Alice and Bob so
they can verify it doesn't leak data. If
she's not happy doing this, or if Alice
and Bob aren't security experts, an
alternative is to have an external party
inspect it and provide assurances to
Alice and Bob that the model is safe to
process their data. Meanwhile, Super
Protocol's open-source certification
center lets anyone confirm that the
whole process runs inside a trusted
confidential
environment. Alice and Bob archive and
upload their data sets using the super
protocol CLI tool called SPCTL. The
utility encrypts the files during
upload. Bob uploads his data set to his
own decentralized
storage. Alice uploads data on her side
to her
storage. Let's see what's inside Alice's
file. Here is the hash, encryption key,
and storage access. The same will be
with Bob's file.
Alice and Bob grant the CVM access and
specify the verified engine's hash and
the ID of the confidential virtual
machine that will process the order. In
our case, it's the compute offer number
eight. Its public key is already
published on the
blockchain. Even Alice herself doesn't
have access to this encrypted data as
only the specified CVM with ID8 has the
private key to decrypt it. Bob's data is
protected in the same way.
Carol places the main order to process
the workload using her uploaded engine
and Alice's and Bob's prepared access
files. She uses the compute offer 8.
When the job is submitted, the trusted
loader checks the CVM certificate,
calculates hashes for the engine data
sets and config, compares them with the
approved list, blocks the job if
anything
diverges. Only if every hash matches
does training start inside the
TE. Data and the engine are only ever
decrypted inside the TE. Even the
participants cannot access them during
execution and everything is protected
from other parties including the owner
of the system executing the
training. Only Carol receives the
encrypted output, the newly trained
model and artifacts. Encryption keys
never leave the TE. though Alice Bob
super protocol and the hardware vendor
remain blind to the
results. Let's check the order status.
As we can see the job is already done.
So we can download the result
now. Here it is. And we can also see
that it was decrypted. SPCTL decrypts it
using Carol's key specified in the
config file. You can find more details
about this process in the super protocol
documentation. Everything is explained
there. Let's unpack the result and check
what's
inside. The logs show that the
application ran as expected. We can see
files located in the input directories,
meaning the input and reference data
were pulled from those directories just
as expected.
Then the training process ran and the
results were saved. All output was
successfully written into the SP output
folder. Here's the trained model, the
PKL file with its weights, evaluation
matrix, and other output
artifacts. All of this was processed in
a fully confidential environment. That
means everything ran on a secure
machine. Security is great. Proof is
better. Before training begins, the
trusted loader creates an integrity
report signed inside the TEE. That
report is later published on OPBNB as
the part of order report, giving anyone
public tamperproof evidence that the job
will run in a certified environment with
the approved
inputs. Here's how we retrieve the
report for this specific order using the
SPCTL command. If the job has already
started, this report has already been
published to the blockchain. What we see
here includes the certificates we
discussed earlier along with a list of
processed inputs and the
timing. The image refers to the actual
executable workload. Its hash matches
exactly the one we saw earlier, the one
trusted by both Alice and Bob. Right
here, same
hash. We can also verify that these
hashes correspond to Alice's and Bob's
inputs. Let's take Alice's data set.
It's hash
matches and now
Bob's same thing. So yes, both Alice's
and Bob's data were used in this job and
it ran with the correct training
engine. The job is complete. The result
is encrypted and delivered only to
Carol. After every job is finished, all
raw inputs are wiped. An order report is
published on chain, giving everyone
public proof that the run was genuine.
The order report isn't just an audit
log. During runtime, an app inside a CVM
can sign data with its private key.
Anyone on chain can verify that the
signature came from a trusted,
decentralized, confidential environment
crucial for web 3 AI
workflows. You've just seen how Super
Protocol lets Alice, Bob, and Carol
train a medical AI without ever exposing
data or models to each other or any
other parties. Super Protocol turns
complex, multi-party, trust heavy
collaboration into a pushb button
workflow. Try it yourself. Build,
verify, run. No expertise in
confidential computing required. Thanks
for
watching. This report shows exactly what
ran, where it ran, and that it followed
the expected logic. All verifiable by
any participant. No NDAs, no manual
audits, just built-in verifiable trust
powered by confidential
computing. It's time to recap.
Throughout this session, we've looked at
real world problems, shared impactful
case studies in the most datadriven
industries, digital marketing and
healthcare, and walked through demos
showing exactly how confidential AI
actually works. Running models on
private data without exposure. deploying
proprietary models without losing
control, fine-tuning without compliance
risk, and verifying execution with
cryptographic
proof. With Super Protocol, you get all
of that in a way that's simple to use,
transparent and verifiable, secure by
design, GPUless, trustless, limitless,
and it's not just a concept, but a
practical path forward for developers.
We invite you to launch your own model
in a confidential environment today. Try
it now. Here are some links to some
starting points. The Super Protocol
website, the SuperAI marketplace,
documentation about Super Protocol, and
Nvidia's article about Super
Protocol. Thank you for your time, and
we hope to see you leveraging
confidential AI soon with Super
Protocol. Have a great day.